what do we do first so the recipe calls
for 150 ml but i will ask
yaya to tell me when to stop this is her
own olive oil that she's made
from her own olive trees wow
perfect okay so now
in here i have garlic and onion chopped
up small
chopped up fine so that's all going in
into our olive oil mix
then
you're shouting at me not to put too
much oregano in
a tablespoon
so she's saying a teaspoon of pepper
ground black pepper
definitely put at least a tablespoon if
not more
and what about salt that's fine uh yaya
likes to go for it
she oh she's saying go for it go for it
i did thank god me too
so now she's um doing some indentations
in the aubergine
because we're gonna fill the aubergine
sorry that's egg
eggplant to you also we're going to
slightly
stuff it with the olive oil garlic and
onion mix wow
so it gives us a little bit of space to
put this into
so the flavors sort of suffuse a little
bit easier
[Music]
i never even knew about this i never
i've never done this
so we are placing the vegetables in the
tray
ready to go if that's while you're
stuffing as well sort of just
dunk them in the um the bowl of olive
oil mix
kind of just sort of completely cover
them in the olive oil
i don't know how yaya does it but i'm
i'm gonna just
i hear you girl i know stuff
yeah yeah yeah it's good it's good now
yeah
yeah these veggies are stuffed and
smothered
she said it's looking really good she
can see this she likes her
yes so now we dunk the potatoes and the
carrots
into our olive oil mix as well so
everything is completely covered
back into the we put it all into the
tray the potatoes the carrots the mix
look at how beautiful
everything is okay i mean i mean and you
know what and it looks
very colorful look yeah thanks that's
what i found as you say nothing to see
here
back with the towel yeah yeah it's
chopping a tomato
she's chopping a tomato and she's just
going to place the slices of tomatoes
into the tray oh yeah no we just put the
whole oh
yeah we just threw them all in there
anastasia will you ask
yaya if you had sort of like an
end of the week uh vegetable could you
could you do that
alaska
don't forget sorry one last thing a
little bit of water goes into the tray
about 16
glass of water oh it goes in no i never
it doesn't stick to the bottom of the
tray
done
you really did leave an extraordinary
blueprint
for something that maybe is an adventure
we should all seek in life i this is so
much more than a cookbook to me
that being said i have loved taziki my
whole life
i've eaten my weight in it and yet i've
never made it
maybe please show us the way
okay look here's my grated cucumber
and i've put it in a in a tea towel
because we need to we need to get rid of
all the water in the cucumber basically
so if you squeeze it downwards then you
should get some nice green juice coming
out
yeah oh yeah yeah we're going to discard
ah oh right look at it now
and then there's more okay you've got it
okay and then you
you need to get your bowl of greek
yogurt yep we have that
it's already in do i put 300 grams of
greek yogurt here
got it cucumbers going in and then
two teaspoons of grated garlic or two
garlic cloves that goes in
got it pinch of salt pinch of salt
quite generous with the black pepper oh
good or
a big pinch of black pepper
i love eating like purees and then just
pouring giant
amounts of cracked black pepper me too
yeah squeeze of lemon
i love when people do it in their hand
like to catch the seeds they look so
sexy and confident
oh yeah the seeds are in there okay i'm
folding it all together
this is awesome this is beautiful
okay next so then i'm just gonna put
that
out onto a plate like can i eat it right
out of the bowl i know
oh here perfect yes here we've got bowls
like that okay perfect
you finish with a little sprinkle of
dill
um everything looks better with a
garnish true story it looks super i mean
look at that
super profesh okay and then
the final piece to resistance is the
greek olive which has to be a kalamata
olive which goes in the middle
i mean i i i may not have looked pretty
while i was making it but
come on look at the end result yeah
don't mind that but
it's great it's my first tzatziki i'm so
excited
okay by the way i gotta taste it now
hold on
i know i want to get this going right
i'm i'm salivating
i really i really do salivate
yum oh my god it's so good
what that is so beautiful okay
hold on i want to read one thing from
the book
because i think it sums up this entire
experience
anastasia and iska yaya
and jessica one of my favorite things
that i read in your book
is from the foreword it says a recipe
not only accompanies us through life it
can
outlive us if we arm the next generation
with the wherewithal to make it an
edible baton
thank you so much so tender for putting
that
into the world and jessica i think
that's so
fitting for what you've just
accomplished
you are arming the next generation with
a baton
that will take care of our children and
save our planet
thank you thank you so much anastasia
and esca and yaya thank you for bringing
us
into your world i can't wait to get this
gym
[Applause]
there you go i'm so excited this is
amazing
go to the drewberrymart show.com for
today's full recipe
and to learn more about everything we
were doing today this
beautiful book grand dishes we'll also
be celebrating the honest company
all day in honor of jessica's ipo thank
you so much you guys
you